mathieu lebrun merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france alors
emmanuel macron n'a pas abordé à votre
cas aujourd'hui votre profession se
sentait abandonnée
ah bah c'est pas abandonner c'est
beaucoup de fatigue depuis un mois pour
défendre leur métier de la colère de
l'incompréhension
quand on voit ce qui se passe
actuellement en france c'est à dire
qu'actuellement
emmanuel macron olivier ferrand edouard
philippe pour notre ancien premier
ministre et notre premier ministre
actuel sont en train de créer des
clusters géant dans notre pays parce
qu'il nous et ne nous écoute pas et il
l'espère des choses très très grave
ces faits viennent ils ne vous écoute
pas c'est à dire que vous aviez proposé
d vous aviez fait formuler des
propositions concrètes pour une
réouverture possible
et bah écoute et oui on a proposé un
protocole sanitaire plus qu'ambitieux un
protocole sanitaire qui du jamais vu et
qui est presque à l'encontre de notre de
notre métier un protocole sanitaire qui
n'existe dans aucun autre métier
actuellement des confiné et actuellement
nous ne sommes pas écoutés et surtout
encore pire c'est à dire que nous avons
nous avons mené les actions nous les
petits patrons discothèque en dehors de
nos syndicats
nous avons rencontré edouard philippe
sur un bout de trottoir avant qu'ils
votent au havre nous avons rencontré v
entes rencontrées par dont olivier
ferrand sur un bouton touareg allemande
en a parlé et il hier nous avons
rencontré grégory emeric et le
responsable technique à la santé pour le
premier ministre qui nous a complètement
avouer que actuellement depuis
notre engagement ils n'ont même pas
encore lieu notre protocole sanitaire
c'est à dire qu'en ce moment pendant je
vous parle je vous parle d'un protocole
sanitaire plus que faure est incroyable
alors c'est quoi justement c'est quoi
justement ce protocole sanitaire qu'est
ce que vous proposez concrètement en
cette période de crise pour que les gens
puissent venir danser en boîte de nuit
nous proposons donc on part sur le
protocole sanitaire des bars on a bien
compris il colle conseil scientifique
avait beaucoup de d'inquiétude au niveau
de la piste de danse on supprime la
piste de danse complètement le port du
masque pour tous les déplacements dans
le bar dans la discothèque parlons sur
la piste de danse
on met des tables on va les écarter
évidemment comme ce qui est prévu dans
les restaurants et dans les bars on
demande juste
évidemment que les gens qui sont autour
de la table on puisse les faire danser
par groupe
on va évidemment les la prise de
température le gel hydroalcoolique
on va et surtout ce qui est important ce
qu'il faut bien écouter c'est une
traçabilité nos clients on a une
application stop coville qui a dû coûter
très cher à notre pays france où
personne ne s'abonne nous allons pas
l'imposer mais fortement conseillée à
nos clients de l'avoir pour rentrer dans
le délicieux tech et si on quelqu'un ne
veulent pas on fera des fiches sur nos
clients c'est à dire que s'ils ne
veulent pas la voir
on prend un nom prénom adresse numéro de
téléphone et demain est ce qui existe en
suisse parce qu'olivier ferrand ne dit
pas la vérité dans l'hémicycle en dix
ans les discothèques ans il le prend
l'exemple de la suisse on pourra avoir
une traçabilité ce qui n'existe pas en
ce moment sur les rave parties les free
parties les fêtes privées qui sont par
milliers en france tous les week-ends
avec moi aux pulsions justement où voir
des images à l'antenne alors que vous
parlez quand vous voyez ces images le
concert de rassemblement sans gestes
barrières sans masque quel est votre
sentiment justement mais c'est à dire
juste comme je voulais dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que l'agencement
l'état est en train de créer tout seul
c'est deuxième vague
on nous parle elle arrive elle est alors
est ce que leur a vraiment lieu
je ne souhaite pas d'ailleurs mais
réellement ont fait l'état
laisse toutes les mais tout ce qui est
possible pour qu'elle soit créé on
laisse n'importe qui créent des soirées
je parle je pense à cette rave party qui
a lieu où marlène schiappa dit bah on
est impuissant alors on amène des
masques du gel ça veut dire qu'en ce
moment la fête non gérer la fête qui
normalement ne doit pas avoir lieu
on le laisse faire et pendant ce temps
là j'ai eu l'exemple d'un patron qui a
tenté d'ouvrir parce que il est pris à
la gorge financièrement 25 ans de sa vie
va partir à la poubelle parce qu'il ne
peut pas ouvrir
on nous demande encore de payer
certaines charges de l'état alors qu'on
me rende plus de chiffre d'affaires a
tenté d'ouvrir samedi et dimanche
on l'a mis en garde à vue monsieur en
garde à vue avec le passage au tribunal
au mois de février mais où on est c'est
à dire des gens qui consacrent leur vie
à des patrons d'établissements
actuellement qui ont payé leur dû à
l'état qui paye des charges on est
traité pour comme des moins que rien des
délinquants c'est incroyable on nous
sommes des professionnels de la fête et
on ne nous écoute pas je râle vraiment
on est outré c'est incroyable ce
justement est-ce que selon vous il ya
une défiance envers le monde de la nuit
est ce que finalement vous souffrez pas
d'une mauvaise réputation
eh ben il ya eu des années sulfureux
soirée disco dès qu'on est d'accord mais
à regarder moi j'ai 40 ans sa fille de
dix ans je suis patron de discothèque
je gère mon établissement comme
n'importe quelle entreprise les années
sulfureuse des années 80 ou peut-être 90
vous voulez c'est fini il reste encore
quelques bruits galeuses comme dans
n'importe quel métier mais c'est fini
tout ça
par contre effectivement si l'état nous
nous laisse nous abandonne nous sommes
des métiers où les banques ne prêtent
pas d'argent
demain si il ya bien deux discothèques
qui dépose le bilan et un jour cette
épidémie sera fini il y aura peut-être
un vaccin
les gens qui auront le cash pour
racheter les discothèques ce sera les
deals ce seront les dealers qui vont
racheter ses discothèques et on
repartira dans ces années sulfureuse
avec des gens qui serviront de nos
établissements comme blanchisserie et là
l'état encore une fois on continue dans
la bêtise dans l'année on écoute pas on
ne nous écoute pas on est en train de
prévenir peut-être une deuxième vague en
train de prévenus
sur la suite de ce qui va se passer et
non la sourde oreille
c'est juste un progression je lance un
appel à emmanuel macron au premier
ministre à olivier véran par pitié
écoutez nous c'est juste incroyable
alors effectivement il ya le volet santé
mais s'ils ne veulent pas nous écouter
au moins trouver une solution avec bercy
avec des moyens financiers comme le
comme l'a fait l'allemagne
effectivement effectivement aujourd'hui
qu'elles sont l'état de vos finances
vous vous avez été obligé de licencier
ah bah non pour l'instant on a le
chômage partiel le chômage partiel de
large c'est à dire que on protège l'état
évite d'avoir des chômeurs un peu
partout en france en plus à cause de
tout ça donc non je n'ai pas licencier
tout le monde est au chômage partiel
mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'on a
des temps plein mais on a beaucoup de
temps partiels qui ne sont pas
remboursés à 100 % actuellement quand je
paye tous les salaires de mes employés
je suis à 2000 j'ai deux mille euros de
ma poche de ma société qui n'est pas
remboursé par l'état et ça depuis le
mois d'avril monsieur donc effectivement
ça devient un peu compliqué même pour ça
je suis à cent trente mille euros de
trésorerie qui sont partis parlent par
les fenêtres c'est c'est juste tout
bonnement incroyable de pouvoir laisser
tout un pan d'une société fin de une
activité comme ça à disparaître à la
poubelle merci bonsoir
et surtout je finirai excusez moi ce qui
me fait chier en avant juste pour
terminer ce qui me choque le plus
actuellement c'est quand je vois notre
gouvernement quant à nous parler d'une
réforme de retraites ou alors on vient
de dépenser 130 millions d'euros pour le
coc vide pour l'attelage la gestion du
coc vide comment peut-on avoir un calcul
des retraites en ayant dépensé déjà 130
millions d'euros on parle de avant ou
après tout est incohérent sa mère a
voulu
merci mathieu lebrun on a bien entendu
votre colère et votre souffrance je
rappelle que vous êtes porte parole des
gérants des discothèques normandie